I grew up a Christian fundamentalist and
but simultaneously this whole like
online thing was happening I was just
really entranced and sucked into it as a
teenager and over the course of the
years I had all kinds of medical
problems the result of which was I
needed someone else's bone marrow and
someone else's lungs in order to stay
alive so quite literally people
connected are like in my body and that
was a pretty major thing for me I'm
trying to understand what that meant
understanding what that what that meant
for my faith and my and my spirituality
around it so I would I started a whole
inquiry of what does this mean for my
life like what is possible when all of
humanity is connected what does it mean
for what I'm supposed to do while I'm
here on all the things that religion
traditionally provides for folks I found
that I had this new faith a new faith in
the connected humanity but didn't know
what that necessarily meant for what the
purpose of my life was and what I came
to understand is that there is something
unique and special about every single
person there's something inside of them
that they are meant to create and it can
be really hard to figure out what that
is but when you do and you have the guts
and determination to actually make it
happen it's the most extraordinary thing
any human can do and if everyone is
doing that everyone is sort of fully
unlocking all that potential inside of
them then that becomes God that is how
we can be the greatest God we can be and
that I sort of guided my life since then
and I wanted to share it with folks I
think one of the big challenges that we
face as humans is how to make connected
humans be greater than the sum of their
parts
it's it's you can see it in like the
inefficiencies that emerge even in sort
of large organizations bureaucracy
government like as people come together
it frequently leads to less things
getting done rather than more things
getting done and so we haven't figured
out how all of that works but that is
the great challenge that is what we
should all strive for and we're starting
to see new models emerge online where
they operate where where groups of
people operate in a more collaborative
but also competitive kind of way open
source software is a great example of
this where the coordination costs have
come down dramatically like I don't have
to ask for somebody's permission to be
able to fork somebody's code and and and
make my own version of it whereas
traditionally collaboration requires a
bunch of people to get into a room and
to sort of all work things out and that
doesn't work when it's a thousand or a
million or ten million people so the
great a great challenge for us is to
figure out what are the ways in which
very very large groups of people can
accomplish things that were never
possible before much of what we call the
sharing economy or even to on-demand
economy it's really just like you know
Airbnb and and you know Kickstarter and
these things really what that is is that
is that's communities accomplishing
things that was just weren't possible
before and the more that we can figure
that out the more that we can scale that
the more successful the more impact that
will have as individuals as leaders but
also as humans what's different and
unique about my faith is that all of us
have the opportunity to impact the kind
of God we are God is not something
that's out there that just is it is all
of us together and so what we do and
what we contribute to it impacts how we
behave there's a huge amount of like bad
behavior online there's trolls even out
ray
culture where um something gets
frequently misinterpreted a tweet and
everybody gets extremely upset about it
and can ruin someone's life in the span
of 10 or 15 minutes it's like utterly
staggering with that power is and it's
it's almost like an adolescent trying to
understand like the immense power that
they now have and we haven't figured out
what that really means for us yet and
how to use it responsibly with great
power comes great responsibility I think
what does that look like for all of
humanity connected Scott Peck wrote a
book a few decades ago is called the
road less traveled and you another book
called a different drum and he talks
about the stages of community there are
four stages the first stage is what he
calls pseudo community and the best way
to describe this is you know how when
you go to a dinner party the everybody's
like pretty polite to each other really
nice and nobody really talks about
politics and religion because that would
get sort of too intense and too crazy
and then everybody goes home afterwards
with their significant other like in the
car and they basically sort of talk dirt
about everybody else that was at the
dinner party that pseudo community and
that is how ninety-nine point nine
percent of the entire world world works
there the second stage of community is
chaos so this is what happens when
people start getting real they start
saying the actual things we chose like
what they're actually thinking and stuff
can get really real really fast it can
get crazy it can be it caps it's called
chaos and then there are two ways out of
chaos the first is you organize your way
out of it you create rules and systems
and processes to work around the
conflict so that everybody can feel more
comfortable again and this again this is
the vast majority of the world works the
other way out is to empty and what that
means is you let go of all of your
preconceived ideas of who somebody else
should be you stop trying to fix
somebody else to make them more like you
and you start to accept people for who
they are if you're able to do that if
the community is able to do that there's
the possibility to sort of reach the
fourth stage which is true community
some people will call this a learning
community and reaching that level is
utterly extraordinaire people can
accomplish things together there's a
there's a cohesiveness and a shared
sense of purpose that is extraordinary
what I believe is happening as everyone
is getting more more connected Twitter
being a really good example is because
it's such a public square is that we're
in chaos we're starting to actually say
the real things to each other that's why
things like gay marriage has moved so
quickly that's why some of these sort of
cultural issues that have sort of SAT
under the surface for so long are
starting to bubble up and get address so
quickly that's what that's what outraged
cultures about people are starting to
experience each other in different ways
and barely know this is not okay that's
not okay that's not okay and is trying
to say it from the safety of their
chairs or their phones to people online
and so we're in chaos and so there's a
lot of folks out that are trying to fix
people it's a lot of that kind of that
happening but if we can get to the point
where we can start accepting each other
and I don't think it's an accident that
all of the efforts around or
transgendered folks and how that's
suddenly it feels like it's suddenly
like emerged into the culture it's
because fundamentally if we can learn to
start accepting people for who they are
that's how we can become one sort of
massive global community a community
made up of millions and millions of
other communities and that's our great
challenge as humans I like to think a
lot about sort of if we are
as individual communities and sort of
like nested structures of communities
how can we then accomplish things we
could have done before but that's what I
think's happening I think it's really
exciting it's not gonna be easy to be
really really painful thankfully it is
it is a war of words frequently and less
a war of bloodshed but it's where I
think